some detail on bounding volume
hierarchies so
i mean you you take the object say the
triangles and group them somehow
together
i mean there are a lot of ways to do
that
this is a combinatorial explosion so you
cannot just
say test each possibility and check
which is the best one
so usually this is scene dependent so
you don't know in beforehand
which bounding volume hierarchy would
give you the best performance
because it could be that through the
light propagation
light very seldomly enters say
one half of the room because there is a
wall with only a small hole
if you do not know that then you would
treat
both rooms with the same priority
and put them very high up in the tree
hierarchy but
if light only travels very seldomly to
half of the room
then you could make one huge node for
only half
of the room and spend all your detail
on the thing where actually something
happens so
the scene usually dictates what kind of
hierarchy is optimal
but this is this doesn't make too much
sense to take this into account because
if you have to run the light simulation
to know what is the most optimal spatial
hierarchy
then you have done the light simulation
already so
you need to use some kind of heuristic
that works for general scenes
and build a hierarchy that optimizes
this heuristic
and the most popular one is the surface
area heuristic
where you compute a cost
for the whole hierarchy and try to find
the one with the lowest cost
and here just to quickly show the
formula
you can read this in detail in the
references i provide
in the last slide of the lecture but
here you sum up two components
so the costs of the inner nodes of the
trees
and the costs of the leaf nodes because
as we already know
the objects so the triangles are in the
leaf node of the tree
so all the intermediate nodes are just
different groupings so from fine to
coarse
but they do not contain content so they
just say if i hit a bounding box
of some intermediate node
then it tells me here my my next level
are
these two bounding boxes continue with
them
then you check the next two bounding
boxes in this volume
and continue recursively until you hit
all the leaf nodes that are appropriate
so that lie along your way and
the costs so there is a inner cost
associated with getting from
one bounding box to the bounding boxes
that lie
in it and the cost of the leaf nodes
which are also the intersection costs of
the triangle stem cells
so c inner in this formula
is the cost of
checking which bounding boxes are
appropriate for continuing through the
tree
and the cost for the leaf node is the
same
for it the tn is the cost for the
triangle intersections and
now the heuristic enters via the
surface areas of objects because the
main assumption
in this heuristic is that you have that
rays lie randomly in your scene
so you don't you don't know in
beforehand
in which uh direction light will travel
so you just assume a random rate
distribution
and then you check how probable
is it that i hit certain objects
so objects with a small surface area
are less probable larger triangles
are more probable and what you want to
do is
that you
give very good groupings as a groupings
that
um that have a high chance
that you actually hit something in them
or that you can exclude
a lot of this and this is here are shown
as a ratio
of the surface areas so
a n is the surface area of node n
this is the volume of the bounding box
which has a certain surface and
this also dictates how probable is it
that i hit this
bounding box and then you have the
surface area of the root so the level
above
so i have my own bounding box at a
certain level of the tree
and my root that contains me is a larger
bounding box
that at least has the extent
of my current one but what you want to
do
is that you want to minimize this cost
so that you
want to have a large surface area of the
root
but a small surface area of your current
bounding box
because this means that you can exclude
a lot of
volume in the space so if you're
going through a huge um bounding box
and you want to decide where do i have
to continue
then the smaller the continuation is the
more
descriptive it is where the scene
content is
the same is done for the um final for
the
final leaf nodes where the triangles are
and now you try to
build a whole hierarchy that optimizes
this cost
so this is not that you can decide at
every level
or at every level you decide what is the
best ratio here that i can achieve
and then this gives you how your
grouping has to be done
there are different heuristics in the
recent literature
that take some more information
of the scene into account so for example
the surface area heuristic
not only assumes random ray distribution
in the scene but also assumes that they
are infinitely long
so that they just travel through the
whole scene and are not blocked by
objects
this is taken into account with
more sophisticated heuristics and
their references on this
and so
yep um if i have a dynamic scene
then a bounding box can get larger yes
one object moves away so a leaflet can
be larger than its root
because the two objects move apart from
them
so the leaf gets larger
now you have to account for that so so
you would have to update
it you would have to propagate this
information up the tree
otherwise um it would fail so to say
because you if you do not hit the root
note
yeah i mean this you have to propagate
up but
um it's the the way of the propagation
is clear
so it's just the grouping upwards till
you have contained even with the dynamic
update what's happening
but with kd trees this is not so easy
because the space itself is subdivided
so you have to somehow
determine where is the object moving to
in which other part of the tree
which is not simple because
it could be that it moves into another
leaf node but the leaf node could be
split already at the very top level of
the tree
so to find the other leaf node where
your kt3
object moves into you have to go up and
down the whole tree
so this is much more costly much more
complicated
here you just propagate it upwards till
it's okay
so i mean the surface area of heuristic
is just that the heuristic
but it's still expensive to compute
the optimal tree for that so
there is not necessarily a unique
solution with the minimal
surface area heuristic but there is one
and since this is expensive
there are also methods how to
approximate
so not to develop a hierarchy with the
optimal
cost but with one that's good enough for
the purpose
and usually this is a trade-off so
the the more time you invest to build
your spatial hierarchy
the better its quality gets and in turn
the more efficient the light simulation
is
so if you don't spend a lot of time to
build your hierarchy
you have bad quality inefficient rate
reversal
during the global illumination
simulation so your
actual rendering takes longer but if you
spend more time on the
hierarchy then
it has better properties for a
propagation
so your light lighting simulation is
more efficient
and it's faster but you see that there
is some kind of trade-off
so i mean if i and usually
this is encoded and
or start again um
usually it depends on how complex your
light simulation is so
if i want to trace say 1000 rays
then the cost of this is very very low
so i just need a i can leave
with a very um approximated
hierarchy so the hierarchy quality can
be very bad
but because i shoot so less rays i will
not feel the difference too much
but if i shoot break counts in the
billions
then even a small increase in
um in optimality
of the hierarchy will give you
significant gains
in your rendering time so what you see
here in this graph
this i just showed that you get a
feeling
what are different methods there are uh
i put the reference to the actual math
to the actual paper where
this is from right next to it
so what you see here are different
methods
on how to generate bounding volume
hierarchies with the surface area
heuristic
so as you see the blue line
the sbbh
um has very low qual
or um start again so what you see here
is on the x-axis
the number of rays that you will shoot
in your lighting simulation so
that means that the more you go to the
right
the more complex the light simulation is
the more quality you want of the final
rendering
the deeper you go into refraction and
reflection levels
things like that
on the other hand on the y-axis
you see how many rays
the lighting simulation can trace per
second
so that means that the higher you go up
the y-axis
the faster your lighting simulation is
and now you have to find some trade-off
so
sbvh constructs very good
spatial hierarchies but is also very
slow
that means that for
for a lightning simulation that only use
a few million rays
the performance is very bad
because most of the time is taken to
build the spatial hierarchy
so for sbh it takes longer to build the
hierarchy
than to do the actual rendering which
doesn't make too much sense
but if you go into the into
one tera race for
computing your final image then it
starts to pay off
because you have a very uh
high performance so you can't raise in
this example on their hardware 400
million rates per second
bl bvh hl hlbvh
on the other hand is a method to
quickly get a spatial hierarchy that's
not very optimal
so you see that for scenes with only a
few million rays
you already get close to the final
performance
so 200 a million race per second
and you're much faster than spvh here
but the more race you shoot the more
you're hurt
by the missing optimality of your
hierarchy
so that means that there is some kind of
sweet spot around
a 10 giga rays where spvh
gets actually better than
hlbvh and in this paper
they propose another method that is
faster to construct
so you see it in the green dotted line
so you quickly it
already gives a significant performance
increasements even for smaller
uh simulations so already at
100 million rays you're better than
hl and you get but you get quickly close
to the performance
of spvh so this is
in this paper this shows that yeah they
found a very good intermediate method
that's only a bit less optimal than the
state of the art before so i
advise you to look into this paper you
see a lot of interesting things there so
how to port pvh construction on the gpu
parallelization issues and
other smart tweaks so
the um i give you the literature so in
pvrt it's the chapter four
and since this is inherently a
geometrical problem
so you want to know where are
triangles in the scene the same
hierarchies can also
be used for um collision detection
because for collision detection
if you want to know could two objects um
collide
then they have to be spatially near to
each other
so if i know that they are far apart
already in the
through the bounding boxes of the tree
then i can ignore this and not compute
the exact
intersection between them and there are
then there are several papers here so
the work of ingo white
more or less started this whole business
in his thesis and then i also give some
recent papers
that usually look into how to do this
fast in the gpu
so this is more or less the current
trend now um there are also
upcoming works to do the same on
this intel manicore architecture so the
xionphi
good this concludes the first part
of this lecture are there any questions
if not then i continue with something
completely different now
i mean this is a very technical topic if
you want to implement it
then you have to look into the papers
anyhow
because i cannot lay out here
all the issues with coding i mean it
would be super boring
and on the other hand it's
also um the surface area heuristic in
itself has proved wealthful
or but
i mean there are a lot of different
approaches so approximation of this
small part approximation of this small
part
so there are many papers that focus
on different partial problems in the
whole
in the whole research problem so going
through a lot of literature is also
suboptimal because due to the rapidly
increasing hardware
capabilities the turnover is also quite
fast
so things that were super smart
approaches say four years ago
do not cut it anymore because gpus now
have
completely different functionality and
can do certain
aspects more efficiently so this is a
rapidly developing topic since
yeah years already so if you want to
implement
that have a look at the current
literature
so there are a few standard papers like
the one
of the of ingrid which have
lasting contributions but mostly in
between are
small optimizations that are focused on
things that are perhaps not relevant
anymore
okay good that's for this